Once the two panes
are showing up on the tablet,
let's modify our code to
handle the list item click.
On the phone, if an item is
clicked in the forecast fragment,
then we must launch the detail activity.
On the tablet UI, once an item in
the forecast fragment is clicked,
we notify the main activity which goes
and replaces the detail fragment.
The reason the two fragments
don't talk to each other
is because we want to maintain
abstraction from each other.
If the forecast list fragment started
assuming that the detailed fragment was
always right next to it, then the
assumption would break, for example on
the phone, where the data fragment
is not inside the main activity.
Therefore, a fragment must
go through it's activity.
An activity must know how to dispatch
the event to the other fragments.
Keep in mind that a fragment
doesn't always has to be
used in the same activity.
In order for the forecast fragment
to talk to the main activity,
we should create a callback interface.
It's a better assumption to say that
the fragment will always be within
an activity that
implements this callback;
then to say that the forecast fragment
will always be inside the main activity.
The detail fragment is a good
example of how a fragment can
be used in two different activates, the
main activity and the detail activity.
So don't rely on get activity
returning a specific activity class.
Using the gist that we provided, use
a callback class to notify the activity
that a list item has been selected.
See the hint below on the
OnItemClickListener.
Then, the activity can either
launch the detail activity or
replace a detail fragment based on
whether it is a phone or tablet.
When you work on this task you'll
run into an issue of how to pass
the selected items you arrive to the
detail fragment, now your instinct might
say to create a custom constructor
where you can pass in the date,
however, we don't normally create
custom fragment constructors.
If you ever rotate the device, for
example, the system can't call
your custom fragment constructor
with the right parameters.
However, it can use the empty
fragment constructor and
initialize it with the same
bundle of arguments used earlier.
So to pass information to initialize
a fragment, create a bundle of
key value pairs and then set that
as the arguments on the fragment.
Don't confuse this arguments bundle
with the savedInstanceState bundle.
Once a fragment has been initialized,
you can't change the arguments, you
can only read from them, as seen here.
On the other hand the save
state bundle is for
storing information once
a fragment has been running, and
you can populate it in the on
save instant state method.
The bundle can preserve state
across orientation changes or
if the fragment or
activity gets killed by the system,
that's why you receive it back again in
the onCreate or onCreateView methods.
Once the detail fragment starts
being displayed on the tablet,
we need to make sure that doesn't get
out of date if the location changes.
If the user went to Settings and
entered in a new location, when they
come back to the main activity,
in the onResume method, we should
detect that the location has changed.
We do this by comparing
the nLocation string
with the location that's
stored in shared preferences.
If there's a difference,
then we find the ForecastFragment and
notify that the location has changed.
Similarly, we find
the DetailFragment and
notify that the location has changed.
Since the DetailFragment is
a dynamically added fragment,
we need to make sure we find the right
instance in the FragmentManager.
We do this by calling findFragmentByTag
and passing in this tag.
We associated this tag
with this fragment
when we first did the fragment
transaction to add it to the screen.
If you didn't already create a tag and
associate it with the detail fragment
in the fragment transaction,
then go ahead and do it now in the
onCreate method of the main activity.
And you'll notice that the detail
fragment tag is just declared as
a string at the top of the file.
After we make the changes
to the main activity
we go over to the detail fragment,
we add a new method onLocationChanged
that takes in a new location string.
First, we try to figure
out what is the date for
the data that we're currently showing.
Then we create a new Uri
with the new location,
as well as the date we're
already displaying.
We update the nUri and
then we restart the loader.
See the instructor notes for the code
related to handling the location change.
This is what the app should
look like when you're done.
When you tap on a different date,
it updates the detail pane.
You can remove any hard coded data
because the layout should be populated
dynamically now.